veamos si podemos simplificar 6 sal a un
medio multiplicado por la raíz quinta de
6 elevado a la tercera potencia okay
pone pausa el vídeo si quieres y bueno
puedes intentarlo pero qué le voy a
poner color a estos exponentes para
seguirles el rastro y aquí tenemos en un
medio en azul
la raíz quinta en rosa y en verde la
tercera potencia muy bien ok entonces
una manera de hacer esto es primero
pensar en esta raíz quinta esto esto es
lo mismo que elevar este 6 a la potencia
a un quinto creo que es un poco más
cómodo entonces pongámoslo de esa forma
6 a la un quinto y esto elevado a la
tercera potencia entonces todo esto
elevado a la tercera potencia hay claro
también vamos a multiplicar por este 6 a
la un medio no no lo vamos a olvidar
entonces por 6
a la un medio y así queda la
multiplicación ahora qué pasa si
elevamos algo a un exponente y a eso lo
elevamos a otro exponente qué pasa qué
que sucede ya conocemos las propiedades
de los exponentes y entonces sabemos que
esto es equivalente a elevar esto al
producto de estos dos exponentes así que
esto es equivalente a 6 a 6 a la 3 por
un quinto es igual a tres quintos
entonces 6 a la tres quintos estoy
usando los colores colores correctos
entonces esto ya multiplicado por seis a
un medio por seis a la un medio seis al
a un medio multiplicado por seis a la
tres quintos y si estás multiplicando
esta base a este exponente y la misma
base a otro exponente de hecho todos
estos todos estos son iguales entonces
voy a poner aquí que son iguales
así que ok esto esto es igual a 6 a 6
elevado
a un medio más tres quintos porque
tienen la misma base simplemente sumamos
los exponentes y ya así que sumemos ok
un medio más tres quintos encontramos el
denominador común el cual será 10 en
este caso el denominador común será 10
así que esto es igual a 6 elevado a 5
sobre 10 más 6 sobre 10 5 sobre 10 más 6
sobre 10 y ahora sumamos estas dos
fracciones esto es igual a 6 a 6 elevado
a la potencia 11 sobre 10 6 a la
potencia 11 sobre 10 y como puedes ver
parecía un monstruo al principio pero no
era era
era solo un gatito cierto no era tan
difícil bueno nos vemos